- All this week to celebrate
our season three premiere,
we've been asking some LA celebrities
to share their LA Top 3.
(upbeat music)
♪ LA Top 3 ♪
(crowd cheers)
These are not your usual spots in LA,
these are spots hand selected
by friends of our show
who have spent years in this great city,
and know what they're talking about.
Today's Top 3 comes from
one of our favorite guests,
one of my favorite guests,
you know him as host of
"American Ninja Warrior" on NBC
and also "American Ninja
Warrior Junior" on Peacock.
It's Matt Iseman.
(crowd cheering)
(Kelly cheers)
- [Matt] What's up!
(Kelly laughs)
- Hello.
I don't know if we can hug.
- Virtual!
- Can we?
I was like, I don't know if we can hug.
- It is so nice to be here.
- I love your energy.
- I love you singing, by the way,
to somebody in the audience,
her first name ain't baby,
it's Kelly, Ms. Clarkson,
- Yes, if you are (indistinct)
Yes, how are you?
- I just wanted to do that.
- I love that.
- I'm great.
I'm so glad, it's so nice to
be here, feeling an audience.
- People.
- I know I've missed it so much.
- It was weird.
Yeah it was really weird, yes.
- Right?
- Well as host of
"American Ninja Warrior",
you also meet some very athletic people
and then people like me.
So I was wondering if you
could give us your top three
places in LA to watch sports.
- Totally, by the way today is 22 years
that I've lived in LA, today.
(crowd cheers)
22 years, I can officially
have a beer in LA now,
but you looked at a lot of great places
like Dodger Stadium or The Forum.
Those are great, but
everyone knows about those.
I want to tell you some places
in LA to see some LA sports.
- Okay okay, wait, what's number three?
- Number three, Manhattan Beach.
Alright look, if you're in
LA, let's go to the beach,
let's get sandy, beach volleyball.
- Sandy.
I've never been to Manhattan Beach.
- Really?
- No, I'm always working.
- You should do a beach concert there.
- I know, I need to go to Manhattan Beach
or just go for fun and
not have to work (laughs)
- That's kind of my
approach, going to the beach.
- What's number two?
- So number two everyone
wants to get up to Malibu,
but one of the great things
you go to the beach there
and you can find surfing.
So Topanga Beach is one
of the earliest beaches
you get right on Malibu.
You get in there, it's unbelievable.
You see the waves.
And once again, I got in, I couldn't surf.
I nearly drowned.
I got back out,
cracked a bottle of wine,
and had the time of my life.
(crowd cheering)
It is awesome, it is gorgeous
and you're in Malibu Kelly.
- I have done that, I actually
tried to surf as well.
- How'd it go?
- It did not go well, first
of all, getting in that thing,
I felt like a sausage, the wetsuit thing.
- Oh that's awful.
- I was like, oh my God.
- Can't they just turn
the heat up on the water?
- And then also like I got out there
and I was so terrified of putting my arms,
my limbs in the water, because sharks,
- Sharks, sharks.
- So they were just like you
got to get up on the board.
And I was like, "No, I don't."
Then I just like, kind
of just went in like this
and then just spent
some time on the beach.
- I feel like that
would be a great TikTok.
You and Charli D'Amelio surfing.
- You know what?
It would be funny.
(Kelly laughing)
Wait, what is that?
I'm sensing a theme.
Is it a beach theme?
What is number one?
- Kelly you are very good at (mumbles)
it is a beach theme.
Now, if you don't know,
I host a little show
called "American Ninja Warrior".
(crowd cheering)
NBC makes me do that.
- I like it.
- One of the cool things, if you go to the
Original Muscle Beach,
not the new one in Venice,
The Original Muscle beach,
right near the Santa Monica Pier.
There are rings out
there, there are ropes.
And every weekend,
a lot of competitors from our
show go out there and train.
They have competitions.
And if you're at all
interested in being fit,
you can go out there, they
will help you get into it.
I have been banned from
attempting any of the obstacles.
So once again, I'll be on
the sidelines with wine,
cheering them on.
- I'll be there.
Well thank you so much Matt.
- Always.